สวัสดีครับพี่เอ๋สวัสดีค่ะน้องอาร์ตี้
สวัสดีค่ะ
กลับมาเจอกับเราสองคนอีกแล้วนะครับที่ไหน
ที่ไหน
ครับอยู่ด้านบนอยู่ด้านบนนะครับวันนี้วัน
จันทร์เหรอคะเห็นสีเหลืองใช่ไหมสีเหลือง
ไม่ได้เกี่ยวกับวันจันทร์ครับวันนี้ยังคง
เป็นวันเสาร์อยู่นะครับวันเสาร์นะคะเสาร์
นี้เสาร์ที่ 13 นะครูอาร์ตี้กับครูทำสี
คลิปเลย
ใช่ครับเพราะว่าอาทิตย์ที่แล้วเนี่ยวัน
จันทร์ไม่ว่างก็เลยมาทำร่วมกันวันเสาร์
เลยนะครับ
แต่ที่เป็นสีเหลืองเนี่ยที่เป็นสีเหลือง
เนี่ยวันนี้สิ่งที่ครัวที่จะมาคุยกับนัก
เรียนเป็นเรื่องเกี่ยวกับสีเหลืองครับสี
เหลืองสิ่งที่เป็นสีเหลือง
ให้ครูเอกคิดไหม
ว่าเป็น
ของกินของกินสีเหลืองของกินสีเหลือง
มันก็มีแอปเปิ้ลสีเหลืองนะเป็นสีเหลืองมี
ฟักทอง
[เพลง]
ทุเรียน
ตอนนี้ทุเรียนเยอะ
ๆยังไม่ได้กินเลยปีนี้
ยังไม่ได้กินข้าวเหนียวมะม่วง
หลายรอบแล้วข้าวเหนียวมะม่วงก็กินไปเยอะ
แล้ว
แต่เรื่องที่เราจะพูดถึงในวันนี้ยังไม่
ถูกสีเหลืองเหมือนกันของกินใช่มะม่วง
เวลาจะแกะน่ะจะเปิดเนี่ย
แกะยากมาก
แล้วเวลาที่เราพูดถึงเรื่องง่ายๆเนี่ยเรา
ก็จะพูดถึงวันนี้แหละคนไทย
ครูอาร์ตี้เดี๋ยวๆเราใช้คำว่าแกะหรือปลอก
นะปกติโคโยตี้
ทำท่าปอกแบบนี้นึกออก
นะ
คะนักเรียนต่อหรือยังคะ
ครูเอก
[เพลง]
ง่ายๆนะคะอ่า
ปอกง่ายๆก็คือ
อะไรๆ
1 กล้วยค่ะ
เราจะมาคุยกันเรื่อง
กล้วยกล้วย
ด้วยนะคะ
ใช่เวลาคนไทยพูดว่ากล้วยๆมันแปลว่าง่ายๆ
นะไม่ได้แปลว่ากล้วยแบบนี้นะแต่ว่าง่ายๆ
ชนิดใช่ไหมคะหลายๆพันธุ์ก็ได้หลายๆชนิดก็
ได้คือกล้วยเนี่ยมีหลายพันธุ์มากนะครับมี
หลายพันธุ์วันนี้ครูอาร์ตี้มีรูปกล้วยมี
กล้วยหลายพันธุ์เลยพริกกล้วยอะไรบ้างคะ
เดี๋ยวเราจะค่อยๆคุยไปทีละกล้วยนะว่า
กล้วยแต่ละชั้นกล้วยแต่ละชนิดเนี่ยเราเอา
ไปทำอะไรได้บ้าง
ทำอะไรกินกินยังไง
แต่ก่อนอื่นต้องรู้จักชื่อก่อนใช่ไหมคะ
ใช่ๆครับ
กล้วยนี้เราเรียกว่ากล้วย
น้ำว้ากล้วยน้ำว้า
[เพลง]
กล้วยน้ำว้า
ก็จะมีกล้วยน้ำว้าแต่บางที่กรุงเทพฯเนี่ย
แพงมากที่ชลบุรีนี่ของคุณแม่ขายเนี่ย 5
บาท
ถูกมากเลย
[เพลง]
ถ้าไปซื้อที่ตลาดเนี่ย 15 บาทประมาณนี้นะ
คะแต่ถ้าใหญ่ก็ 30
[เพลง]
ถ้าซื้อในห้างก็จะแพงหน่อยแต่ถ้าซื้อใน
ตลาดก็จะถูกลงมาหน่อย
[เพลง]
จะบอกว่ากล้วยน้ำว้าเนี่ยเป็นกล้วยที่คน
ไทยกินเยอะนะกินง่ายๆเพราะว่าลูกไม่ใหญ่
มากลูกไม่ใหญ่มากลูกเล็กๆพอดีกินก็ไม่
อิ่มมากนะครับ
[เพลง]
แบบนี้เราเรียกว่า 1 ลูกนะ 1 ลูก
ทั้งหมดเนี่ยทั้งหมดเนี่ยเราเรียกว่า 1
หวี
คำถามก็คือครูเอ๋กิน 4 ลูก
เอาแบบ
หิ้วๆหรือแบบว่าหิวนิดหน่อยหรือว่าไม่
เอาแบบปกติปกติถ้ามีกล้วยวางอยู่บนโต๊ะ
กินกล้วยดีกว่าหยิบขึ้นมา
กินกี่ลูก
น้อยจังทำไมกินน้อยจังคือครูเอ๋เนี่ยไม่
ชอบกินกล้วย
ครูเอ๋เด็กๆอ่ะ
ที่บ้านเนี่ยมีกล้วย
เยอะใช่ไหมคะ
ไม่อยากกินกล้วยน้ำว้ากล้วยน้ำว้านะ
แบบนี้ค่ะ
จะไม่ค่อยกินแต่กล้วยน้ำว้าเนี่ยดีที่สุด
ดีที่สุดเลยคนไทยนะเอากล้วยน้ำว้าสุก
เนี่ยนักเรียนมาย่างย่างแล้วก็ไปบดแล้วก็
ใส่อาจจะใส่ฟักทองใส่อะไรแล้วก็ให้เด็กๆ
กินสำหรับร่างกายแข็งแรงแล้วก็โตนะคะแต่
ว่าครูเอ๋มีกล้วยที่บ้านน้ำหวานเป็นอาหาร
นก
กินเหรอครับให้นกกับให้สามีกินแบ่งกันคน
ละครึ่งนะคะแต่ครูเอ๋ไม่ค่อยกินแต่ถ้าหิว
แบบหิวมากๆแล้วไม่มีอะไรเลย
ไม่มีไม่มีอาหาร
ไม่มีแล้ว
กล้วยน้ำว้า
[เพลง]
ถ้ามีอย่างอื่นก็ไม่กินกล้วยนะคะ
เพราะว่าเวลาที่เราปอกมันออกมาแล้วเนี่ย
ปลอกเปลือกมันออกมาแล้วเนี่ยครับเราก็
กลัวจะต้องกินให้หมดเพราะว่ากรอกเวลาปลอก
เราต้องปอกทั้งลูกใช่ไหมบอกแล้วเรากิน
ครึ่งเดียวแล้วอีกครึ่งนึงทำยังไงเก็บไม่
ได้
[เสียงหัวเราะ]
ใจดีให้กินหน่อย
ช่วยกินหน่อย
[เพลง]
แล้วก็
ถ้าแบบนั้นโอเคมีคนช่วยกินมีคนช่วยกิน
จริงๆก็ลูกเล็กๆนะคะแต่เพียงแต่ว่าครูเอก
ไม่ค่อยชอบกินกล้วยน้ำว้า
กินได้แต่ว่า
ไม่ได้ชอบมาก
ๆนะคะ
ที่คนไทยเอาไปทำขนม
เปลี่ยนน่าจะเคยเห็นแล้วก็เคยกินแล้วก็
ได้นะครับ
ไม่อยากกินแบบนี้บางคนบอกแบบนี้ไม่อร่อย
ฉะนั้นกินแบบไหนค่ะเราเอาไปทำ
กล้วยทอดอันนี้กินค่ะ
[เพลง]
มันจะมี 1 ชิ้นเยอะเลย
1 ลูกจะได้ 3 ชิ้น
สามารถกินได้ 6 ชิ้นเลย
กินได้เยอะเลยเพราะว่าอร่อยกว่าใช่ไหม
อร่อยกว่า
[เพลง]
เอามาทอดนั่นแหละ
เรียกว่ากล้วยทอดกล้วยแขก
ทำมาจากกล้วยน้ำว้าเหมือนกันอันนี้เป็น
ปกติชอบอันนี้ที่หนึ่ง
อันที่ 2
ไม่เป็นไรไม่แย่งกัน
มีน้ำอันนี้เป็นน้ำกะทิ
นอกจากกล้วยทอดเรากล้วยบวชชีแล้วเรายังทำ
ขนมอย่างอื่นได้เพราะว่ากล้วยน้ำว้าคนไทย
กินเยอะไงขนมได้หลายๆแบบนะครับนี่
อะไรบ้างคะมีอะไรบ้างใช่ไหมครับอันนี้
เป็นกล้วยน้ำว้าเนี่ยเราเอามาเรามาปิ้ง
ใช่ไหมเรียกปิ้งหรือเรียกยากไง
กล้วยปิ้งก็ได้แต่มากๆกรวยปิ้ง
ก็ชอบเหมือนกันอันนี้กล้วยปิ้งนะครับอัน
นี้เวลาไปสั่งนะนักเรียนสามารถบอกเขาได้
ว่าเอาแบบเขาเรียกอะไรนะ
หรือว่าไม่ทับนะคะแล้วก็คือเป็นลูกๆกลมๆ
เลยก็ได้แล้วก็เอาแบบใส่อะไรนะใส่ใส่น้ำ
ขิง
ซอสหวานๆเนี่ยครับเป็นกะทิเป็นกะทิเป็น
น้ำตาลนะครับมาจากมะพร้าวนะคะใส่ก็ได้ไม่
ใส่ก็ได้นะคะ
[เพลง]
อันที่อันที่ชอบขึ้นมามากอีกหน่อยนึงคือ
อันนี้ครับอะไรเอ่ยกลัวที่คิดว่าอันนี้
นักเรียนน่าจะเคยน่าจะเคยกินนะน่าจะรู้
สึก
อันนี้มีกล้วยอยู่ข้างในเห็นไหมครับอ่า
อันนี้เป็นไงข้างนอกเนี่ยเป็นข้าวเหนียว
เราเรียกมันว่าพ่อต้ม
ข้าวต้มกล้วย
หรือบางทีก็เรียกข้าวต้ม
มัดพอเรามีเชือกมีเชือกมัดมันตรงนี้ก็เลย
เรียกว่าข้าวต้ม
ในรูปที่ครูอาร์ตี้
เป็นต่อใช่ครับทำมาจากไม้ไผ่
ข้าวต้มมัดก็มีข้าวเหนียวกับกล้วยนะคะ
วันที่ชอบเหรอคะชอบครับชอบ
หวัดที่ชอบขนมจากกล้วยนะ
ใช่ครับเพราะว่ากลัวตี้ชอบขนมชอบขนมไทยนะ
[เพลง]
ครับสำหรับคนที่นะขนมไทยก็จะทำมาจากผลไม้
ก็เยอะถึงคุณเนอะ
ส่วนใหญ่นะ
[เพลง]
เวลากินจะกินง่ายกว่าเพราะเป็นแผ่นแบนๆ
มันบางๆนะแผ่นบางๆแบบนี้
เราเรียกว่าอะไรครับ
กล้วยฉาบ
กล้วย
ซึ่งอาจจะเป็นกล้วยน้ำว้าหรือกล้วยอื่นๆ
ก็ได้นะคะนักเรียนเอามาฝานเนาะ
อ่ากล้วยที่ยังเป็นสีเขียวอยู่ใช่ครับสี
เขียวไหมหรือว่าเขียวๆเหลืองๆ
เราเรียกว่ากำลังจะสุกเรียก
[เพลง]
แล้วก็เอามาฝานนะคะแล้วก็เอาไปล้างก่อนนะ
คะสานแล้วก็เอาไปทอด
มันเหมือนเฟรนช์ฟรายส์ค่ะนักเรียน
เสร็จแล้วรสช้อนเสร็จแล้วก็มี
น้ำตาลที่นักเรียนใส่กาแฟค่ะเขามีกระทะ
ใหญ่ๆแล้วก็เอาน้ำตาลใส่แล้วน้ำใส่แล้วก็
คน
เหนียวนะ
แล้วก็เอากล้วยที่ทอดเสร็จน่ะ
ใส่แล้วก็
พ่อคลุกเสร็จน้ำตาลก็จะเกาะที่กล้วยเป็น
สีสีขาวๆแบบนี้แหละ
อร่อยแต่ว่าตอนนี้คนกลัวอ้วนก็เลยไม่ใส่
น้ำตาลจะใส่เกลือนิดนึงใส่น้ำตาลนิดหน่อย
ใส่เกลือลงไปด้วยนะครับจะไม่หวานมาก
เหมือนเมื่อก่อนแล้วนะ
ตาลมีไหมก็มีนิดหน่อยครับ
เพราะว่ากล้วยเขาหวานอยู่แล้ว
เราไม่ต้องใส่น้ำตาลเยอะ
พูดแล้วก็อยากกิน
อันนี้ได้มา 1 กล้วยแล้วนะนี่กล้วยแรก
กล้วยน้ำว้าต่อไปเราไปที่เราไปที่กล้วย
กล้วยอันนี้ครับ
[เพลง]
กล้วยหอมกล้วยน้ำว้ากับกล้วยหอมกล้วยที่
กินกล้วยหอมมากกว่า
[เพลง]
กล้วยหอมจะมีรสชาติที่แตกต่างจากกล้วย
น้ำว้านิดหน่อยปกติก็เลยชอบกล้วยหอมมาก
กว่า
[เพลง]
ส่วนครูเอ๋
ไม่กินทำไมไม่กินกล้วยหอมกล้วยหอมมันหอม
มันมีซัลเฟอร์ไง
มันจะทำให้เกิดแก๊ส
สำหรับบางคนไม่เป็นไรแต่สำหรับตัวเองไม่
ได้เอกก็เลยไม่กินกล้วยหอมแต่กินกล้วย
น้ำว้านิดนึง
กล้วยหอมลูกจะใหญ่กว่านะลูก
ถ้าเปรียบเทียบกันในรูปเนี่ย
กล้วยน้ำว้าจะลูกสั้นๆแต่กล้วยหอมลูกเขา
จะยาวกว่าลูกเขาจะใหญ่กว่า
แล้วเวลากินเนี่ยปกติก็กิน 1 ลูกอยู่ดี
เพราะว่าเวลาปอกออกมาแล้วเนี่ยต้องกินให้
หมดคนเดียวนะครับเอ่อ
กล้วยหอมไม่กินเพราะว่ากล้วยน้ำว้า
รักกล้วยหอมปุ๋ยต้องหั่นๆๆเป็น 4 เลยนะ
[เพลง]
ใส่กับไอติมใช่ไหมใช่ๆเรากล้วยหอมเนี่ย
เราเอาไปใส่ไอติมนะครับ
ขนมที่ทำมาจากกล้วยหอม
ขนมอะไรคะอันนี้อันนี้น่าจะเป็นคนน่าจะ
รู้จักดีโดยเฉพาะครูเอ๋ก็น่าจะต้องรู้จัก
กล้วยหอมนะครับหลายๆคนก็น่าจะเคยกินนะ
ครับอร่อยๆก็ชอบนะคะ
ข้างบนอันนี้เป็นโรตีโรตีกล้วยโรตีกล้วย
หอม
[เพลง]
เราใส่กล้วยหอม
บ่อยกว่าบ่อยกว่าโรตีกล้วยหอม
ไม่ต้องถามตัวเองนะ
ไม่กินกล้วยหอมถ้างั้นเราไปดูกล้วยต่อไป
อยากรู้ว่านักเรียนกินไหม
นักเรียนกินไหม
ถ้านักเรียนมาเมืองไทยก็เคยเห็นคนต่าง
ชาติกินโรตีกล้วยหอมนะคะแต่เค้กกล้วยหอม
ก็น่าจะกินเนาะ
แต่ถ้านักเรียนรู้จักหรือว่าคุ้นเคยเนี่ย
น่าจะอยู่ในไอติมอย่างที่ครูเอ๋บอก
Banana  split ใช่ๆเราใช้กล้วยหอมนะครับ
ในการทำ
ต่อไปเราไปดูกล้วยกล้วย
อะไร
กล้วย
ยิ้มชอบใจแสดงว่าอันนี้ชอบใช่ไหมใช่
น้ำหวานนิดหน่อยนะใช่
น้ำหวานจะไม่เหมือนกล้วยหอม
กล้วยไข่
ได้ค่ะ
กินได้เหมือนกัน 2 ลูกเลยเพราะว่าลูกเล็ก
ลูกเล็กใช่ไหม 2-3 ลูกได้
ไหนเราชอบเราก็กินเยอะหน่อยนะครับ
กล้วยไข่เอาไปทำขนมอะไรได้บ้างครับ
กล้วยเชื่อม
กินหมดเลยหรอ
หวานๆเค็มๆใช่ไหม
น่ากินจังเลยนะครับ
[เพลง]
นักเรียน
คิดว่าใครทำก็อร่อยนะเพราะมันไม่ยากนะ
ครับไม่ยากอ๋อมันยากตรงเลือกกล้วยเพราะ
ว่าถ้าเอามาทำแบบนี้ถ้ากล้วยเหลืองสุกไม่
อร่อยต้องกล้วยแบบแบบกำลังสีข้างนอกสิยัง
เขียวๆอยู่อ่ะค่ะ
แต่เขียวอาจจะมีเขียวๆเหลืองๆปนๆกันใช่
ไหมใช่เพราะต้องเป็นกล้วยที่แข็งๆนิดนึง
อ่ะถ้ากล้วยนิ่มๆไม่อร่อยต้องแข็งๆนิดนึง
เละเกินไปถ้ากล้วยนิ่มนะครับก็กล้วยแข็งๆ
หน่อย
โอเควันนี้ครัวตี้ก็ชอบนะอันนี้ๆอันนี้
กลัวตี้ชอบมากกว่ากล้วยเชื่อมนิดนึงอ๋อ
เรียกว่าอะไรคะ
เอออันนี้มันมีส่วนประกอบตรงนี้ครับที่
เป็นส่วนผสมตัวนี้ที่ก็ชอบอันนี้เราเรียก
ว่ากล้วยข้าวเม่า
ๆก็คือจะมีกล้วยแล้วก็ห่อด้วยข้าวเม่า
ด้วยข้าวเม่า
ครับ
คือข้าวที่เราออกไปตำให้มัน
เอาไปทุบให้มันแบนๆใช่ไหม
คือต้องบอกอย่างนี้ค่ะข้าวเม่าก็คือข้าว
คือคนไทยปลูกข้าวแล้วพอข้าวเป็นสีเหลือง
ก็คือข้าวแกงแล้วใช่ไหมคะแต่ข้าวเม่า
เนี่ยยังไม่แก่ขนาดนั้นข้าวประมาณสีเขียว
ๆแต่ยังนิ่มๆอยู่
ทั้งเปลือกเลยคือข้าวจะมีเปลือกแล้วก็มี
กระทะแล้วก็เอามาใส่เอาข้าวใส่แล้วก็คั่ว
คั่วเสร็จแล้วข้าวสุกนะ
เหมือนนักเรียนทำป๊อปคอร์น
ๆให้มันสุกทั่วๆกันใช่แล้วก็เอามาเอามาตำ
เอาข้าวใส่แล้วก็มีครบตาม
อ่า
เปลือกก็จะออกไปเอาเปลือกออกไปให้เหลือ
แต่ข้าวอย่างเดียวนะครับ
หอมๆหวานๆเรียกว่าข้าวเม่านั่นเองก็คือ
อันนี้
นะคะ
เอามาห่อกล้วยแล้วก็ไปใส่ที่แป้งแล้วก็
ทอด
โอ้อันนี้ทำยากหน่อย
อร่อยมากอร่อยมาก
ที่ชลบุรีอร่อยค่ะ
[เพลง]
แล้วใครจะกินกล้วยต้องกินผอมๆกันนะนัก
เรียนกินพอกันจะได้รสชาติของข้าวเม่าในรส
ชาติของกล้วยพร้อมๆกันครูเอกคนไม่ดีค่ะ
นักเรียน
ไปครับกล้วยต่อไปยังไม่หมดครับต่อไปสู่
กล้วยอีกกล้วยหนึ่งกล้วยนี้ครับ
อันนี้ลูกจะใหญ่กว่ากล้วยน้ำว้านิดหน่อย
นะครับแต่จะยาวไม่เท่ากล้วยหอมกล้วยหอม
ยาวกว่า
กล้วย
สีเหลือง
[เพลง]
ชื่ออะไรคะ
กล้วยกล้วย
เวลากินกล้วยหักมุกเนี่ยส่วนใหญ่โคโยตี้
ไม่กินตอนที่มันเป็นกล้วยสุกแบบนี้นะ
อ๋อไม่มีใครกิน
ไม่มีใครกิน
น้ำไม่เคยไม่เคยกินแล้วก็ไม่เห็นใครกินนะ
คือครูเอ๋ก็ไม่แน่ใจว่ามีคนกินไหมแต่ว่า
ไม่เห็นค่ะคนที่คิดว่ามันก็คงกินได้แต่
อาจจะไม่อร่อยเท่าเราต้องเอาไปทำอะไรก่อน
ครับเอาไปย่างเอาไปปิ้ง
ก่อนนะครับข้างล่างก็จะเป็นไฟนะเป็นไฟ
เป็นฝั่งแดงๆนี่เรากล้วยไว้ข้างบนแล้ว
เวลามันสุกเนี่ยมันจะมีสีเหลืองหอมอ่า
สวยดีมากเลยใช่ไหม
อร่อยมาก
[เพลง]
ก็คืออ่า 30 บาทหรือ 35 บาท
แต่ว่า
ครูเอกเคยเจอที่เยาวราชนะคะเยาวราชก็คือ
บริเวณที่เป็นคนจีนในประเทศไทยก็ 1 ลูก 20
บาท
[เพลง]
กล้วยดิบ 1 หวีก็ 70 บาทแล้ว
1 หวีก็มีทั้งหลายลูกนะ 1 หวีก็มี
มานานว่าโอเค 20 บาทไม่เป็นไร
เราก็อิ่มพอดีใช่ไหม
แล้วครับไม่ต้องกิน 3 ลูกกิน 3 ลูกไม่หมด
เยอะเกินไป
ไม่ต้องกินข้าวเลยกินกล้วยอย่างเดียวเลย
นะ
ทำกล้วยฉาบ
ได้กล้วยน้ำว้าทำกล้วยฉาบแล้วก็กล้วยหัก
มุกทำกล้วยฉาบครูเอ๋ชอบกล้วยหักมุกเอาไป
ทำกล้วยฉาบมากกว่า
มันจะแข็งแล้วก็กรอบมากกว่าใช่ไหมครับ
แล้วก็เอาไปทำยาได้นะอ๋อใช่ทำยาได้ด้วย
แต่ว่าต้องเป็นกล้วยดิบใช่ไหมครับ
[เพลง]
เขียวๆแบบนี้ค่ะเขาจะเอาเอาไปอะไรนะเอา
เปลือกออกนิดหน่อยแล้วก็จะ
ซอยบางๆแล้วก็มันเล็กๆใช่ไหมครับ
ร้อนๆแล้วก็ให้แห้งแต่ว่า
คนไทยเอาไปตากแดดอ่ะค่ะง่ายกว่าครับ
พอแห้งดีแล้วเนี่ยก็เอามาบดๆเป็นผงๆแบบ
นี้เป็นผงค่ะแล้วก็เวลากินก็ใส่น้ำผึ้ง
นิดนึง
อ๋อจะได้มีรสหวานเพิ่มขึ้นนะครับ
วินนี่เดอะพูลชอบกิน
นั่นเอง
นะคะกินแล้วเป็นยังไงมีประโยชน์ยังไงครับ
มีสรรพคุณอะไรก็คือเวลานักเรียนรู้จักกรด
ไหลย้อนไหมคะคือว่าเวลาแบบกินอาหารแล้ว
อ่ะมันมีกรดแล้วมันไหลขึ้นมาแล้วเราจะปวด
ท้อง
ปวดท้องเขาให้กินกล้วยบด
ตอนก่อนกินอาหารครึ่งชั่วโมงอ๋อกินไปก่อน
ที่จะกินอาหารตายครึ่งชั่วโมง
อาจจะเช้าเย็นหรือซื้อ 3 มื้อก็ได้เช้า
กลางวันเย็นก็ได้กินประมาณ 2 ช้อน
ราคา 2 ช้อนแล้วก็จะทำให้กรดไหลย้อนออกมา
เนี่ย
หาย
เขาบอกว่าด้วย
[เพลง]
อันนี้บางคนก็ทำจากกล้วยน้ำว้าแต่ที่ครู
เอกกินน่ะทำจากกล้วยหักมุก
อาหารแล้วเรายังกินกล้วยเป็นยาได้ด้วย
ว้าวมีประโยชน์เยอะมากเลยครับกล้วยทำยาก
จังเลยอ่ะมีขายไหมเป็นแบบแคปซูล
วันนี้เราก็ได้รู้เรื่องราวเกี่ยวกับ
กล้วยชนิดต่างๆนะครับของไทยที่เราเอามาทำ
อาหารที่เรามากินกันใช่ก็รู้จักไป 3 ชนิด
แต่ว่านักเรียนอาจจะอยากรู้จักชื่อกล้วย
ที่เหลืออีก 2 อย่างอ่ะค่ะ
อ๋ออีก 2 อย่างใช่ไหมโอเคเห็นแล้วไม่ต้อง
บอก
โอเคเดี๋ยวนะ
นักเรียนเห็นในรูปนี้ก็จะอยู่เนี่ยครับ
ลูกเล็กๆเร็วๆเล็กกว่ากล้วยไข่นะเล็กกว่า
กล้วยไข่นะครับ
[เพลง]
เพราะว่ามีขนาดเล็กเล็กเท่ากับเหมือนกับ
เป็นนิ้วมือเป็นนิ้วมือเราก็เลยเรียกว่า
กล้วยเล็บมือนะ
คะ
อันนี้ครูเอกไม่เคยกินนะคะ
[เพลง]
หากเคยเห็นที่ตลาดที่ตลาดเคยเห็นมีขายนะ
แต่ก็ไม่ได้สนใจก็จะลองซื้อมากินอะไร
อย่างนี้กลัวไม่อร่อยกลัวไม่อร่อยซื้อ
กล้วยหอมดีกว่านะซื้อกล้วยน้ำว้ากินง่าย
กว่ากินที่เคยกินนะคะ
โอเควันนี้เรื่องกล้วยๆนะครับ
เดี๋ยวคราวหน้านะครับเราจะมีเรื่องอะไรมา
คุยกันเดี๋ยวนักเรียนคอยติดตามกันนะครับ
วันนี้เราสองคนต้องลาไปก่อนนะครับ
สวัสดีครับพี่เอ๋สวัสดีค่ะนักเรียนบ๊าย
บาย